johnatan bonjour revenons à présent sur
ce groupe de volontaires combattants
nationalistes
que vous avez rencontrées on a vu votre
reportage à l'instant de natal est ce
que c'est volontaire vous ensemble est
effectivement
extrémistes les avez vous trouvés bien
formés
alors soyons clairs pour ce qui est de
la partie idéologique nous avons
évidemment posé beaucoup de questions
pour savoir exactement où nous mettions
les pieds et à aucun moment nous n'avons
eu le sentiment d'être d'être face à une
population à des jeunes qui étaient qui
était extrémistes qui était
politiquement
idéologisé il s'agit il s'agit en
réalité de gens qui ne savaient pas où
s'engager de volontaires qui avaient
envie de se battre pour leur pays pour
défendre en particulier leur ville leur
capitale kiev et qui ont trouvé là un
moyen de participer à cette lutte et
c'est ce qui se passe souvent avec avec
de nombreux régiments de nombreux
bataillon de ce type qui certes ont la
plupart du temps unis d'une idéologie
fondatrice
ultra nationaliste mais qu'ils ont dans
leurs rangs de nombreux membres qui
cherchent tout simplement un endroit où
se battre lorsqu'il ne peuvent pas le
faire dans l'armée régulière donc donc
voilà pas de pas de deux jeunes pas de
gens idéologisé lors de notre tournage
mais plutôt des gens disons normaux
d'anciens avocats d'anciens d' ancien
chauffeur des gens qui qui pratiquaient
des métiers tout à fait tout à fait
normaux avant la guerre